foreign
Industries and transforming the way we
will leave and work it encompasses a
wide range of Technologies including
machine learning deep learning natural
language processing computer vision and
many more with its ability to analyze
vast amount of data and make Intelligent
Decisions AI has become a game changer
across various domains hi everyone
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
this AI roadmap guides you in navigating
the path towards building a successful
career in artificial intelligence the
ultimate goal of artificial intelligence
is to create intelligent missions that
can perform complex tasks exhibit
human-like intelligence and contribute
positivity to society AI presents
exciting career opportunity in various
Industries and sectors roles like AI
engineer data scientists NLP Engineers
computer vision Engineers AI research
scientists robotic engineers and many
more offer exciting prospects for
working with cutting ITS Technologies
and making an impact through artificial
intelligence Innovation according to
last year the average reported salary of
an AI engineer in the United States is
around 105 000 per year however in India
it is still like per annum leading
companies worldwide are fully aware of
the immense value of AI and are actively
pursuing skilled AI Engineers to
contribute to their research development
and implementations of AI technology
among this top companies are Google
Microsoft Amazon Goldman Sachs apple and
JPMorgan Chase therefore top companies
hiring AI engineer provide excellent
opportunity for aspiring professionals
on that note eliminate your career with
our Ai and ml course developed in
partnership with Purdue University and
IBM gain expertise in high demand skills
such as machine learning deep learning
NLP computer vision reinforcement
learning charge GPT generative Ai
explainable Ai and more Unleash Your
Potential and unlock exciting
opportunity in the world of AI and ml
this course cover tools like python
tensorflow
and many more so hurry up and find the
course Link in the description box for
more details our Learners have
experienced huge success in their
careers listen to their experience
finally simply learn course reviews Link
in the description box without any
further delay let's dive into the topic
now if you decide to become an AI
engineer here are the steps you can
follow to achieve your goal firstly
obtain a strong foundation in
mathematics and programming gain a
strong foundation in creating mathematic
Concepts like linear algebra calculus
and probability theory in addition to
that it is crucial to occur Mastery of a
programming languages like python
commonly used in Ai and become
proficient in coding then earn a degree
in a relevant field that means earn a
bachelor's or master degree in computer
science data science AI or a related
field to gain a comprehensive
understanding of AI principles and
techniques next gain knowledge in
machine learning and deep learning to
become a AI engineer develop similarity
with ML algorithms neural networks and
deep learning Frameworks example
tensorflow by torch to train and
optimize models using real world data
set followed by that work on practical
projects gain hands-on experience and
showcase your skills by working on AI
projects moreover will a portfolio of
projects demonstrating your ability to
solve AI problems embracing potential
employers then stay updated with the
latest advancements stay updated with
the latest trends and research in AI a
rapidly involving field and expanding
your knowledge by reading research
papers participating in online courses
and workshops and joining AI communities
next collaborate and network engage with
AI communities attend conference
participate in online forums to connect
with Professionals in this field
collaborating with others can enhance
your learning experience and open new
opportunities later seek internships or
entry-level positions gain practical
experience through AI internships or
entry-level roles in industry or
research institutions this provides
valuable exposures and help develop your
skills finally continuously learn and
adapt in the rapidly involving field of
AI stay updated on new developments
explore specialized areas and embrace
emerging Technologies and tools to
pursue a career as an AI engineer now
that we have covered the extension steps
to become an AI engineer let's explore
the necessary programming languages and
algorithms for aspiring AI Engineers so
mastering programming languages like
python are Java and C plus plus is vital
for occurring Proficiency in AI this
language is enables you to construct a
deploy models effectively additionally
it would help if you gain a thorough
understanding of machine learning
algorithms such as linear regressions K
nearest neighbors name base and support
Vector missions this languages and
algorithms are fundamental tools in the
field of AI they will enable you to
develop and Implement effective
artificial intelligence models now let's
take a minute to hear from our Learners
who have experienced huge success in
their career we need to keep updating
your skills the course material was
comprehensive and the faculty was
extremely experienced The Faculty was
able to adjust their teaching style in
order to cater to the overall skill set
of the class in the rapidly evolving
world of technology it's important to
keep up Skilling for every working
professional stay relevant continue
learning
with this we have come to the end of
this artificial intelligence roadmap in
2023 I hope this video was informative
and interesting if you have any queries
regarding topics covered in this video
or need help opting for this course
please let us know in the comment
section below our team of experts will
happily resolve all your queries as soon
as possible until next time thank you
stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign